[Music]
my girlfriend's name is Carmella and
she's 27 years old and she lives in
Barbados
she is this hot thick beautiful woman
this goddess like cardi B and Megan the
stallion combined like she has all that
I met Carmella on an online dating site
me and Carmella chat every day about
everything
from like random stuff to our plans for
the future we've been talking for almost
four years now and I would describe it
as like a soulmate connection like we're
made for each other
I've never been in love before but this
feeling I feel for Carmella is just like
warm
I was like heartburn but like a good
heartburn
Carmella doesn't work right now I bet
she is planning on uh going to school
and she does hair on the side
when she talks about like what she wants
to do in the future like her goals and
stuff like that really makes me happy
and like her one started business and
I'm like you know you can do it you know
I'm pushing her and being that that
support factor for her
Carmella is the sweetest thing ever she
gives me confidence she makes me happy
she's extremely emotionally supportive
especially when my mom got sick so she
was there for me I really appreciated
that from her
right here I was letting her know that
I'm thinking of her and then she's
letting me know that looked like a teddy
bear with facial hair that's so adorable
um
we only communicate on Snapchat but we
do have you know naughty Snapchat
sessions
we do send like sexy pictures and videos
you know
what's that
the booty
video or uh unfortunately not
she's never video chatted me
yeah no I did once but she didn't say
anything so I didn't really
uh you know I took it as a no
maybe she's not comfortable
or maybe she doesn't like video chatting
I know a lot of people don't
I do plan on seeing Carmella soon
um I'm just trying to see if I can find
a flight that's in my small budget so
that's pretty much what I'm waiting for
at this moment
I'm excited to share like my cooking
skills with someone other than my mom
Carmel is my girlfriend right now but um
hopefully soon my wife